you may have heard of the controversy
surrounding snapchat they they had added
a channel called the after dark channel
and it was going to be dedicated
exclusively to pornographic content and
of course this channel would have been
brought to you by or brought to your
child by I should say by that trash heap
of a publication known as Cosmo and I
say would be because they've now
discontinued the channel after backlash
and so they're not gonna have that
anymore but still the point about
snapchat still stands it is a toxic dump
and nothing worthwhile can be found
there and you shouldn't let your kid
anywhere near it
and I wrote a piece yesterday talking
about why
we need to get our kids off of snapchat
and off of social media in general and
to whatever extent possible off of the
Internet's as well I'm not going to
repeat the whole thing
as far snapchat goes
is a conversation that we shouldn't
really need to have
it's a sight widely known for its sexual
content because sexual content is part
of the whole point of the thing it's
part of why it was invented is for
sexual content why do you think when
when people decide they're going to
invent this tool where you can send and
interact with photos and then videos
that delete themselves after a few
seconds
what I mean when most when most people
on the internet see that feature what
are they thinking how do you think
they're gonna use it so of course it's
gonna end up being a site that's overrun
with sexual content it's one of the
primary points of the thing in the first
place so why would
we as parents allow our kids into that
minefield
I try not to condemn other parents or to
judge them too harshly
especially when I'm dealing with older
parents who have older kids and so
they've been through things I haven't
been through they've they have met
challenges that I haven't met yet and I
understand that but there are some
things that are just very difficult to
understand and allowing your kid to use
snapchat well that that's a hard one for
me to wrap my head around now if you
tell me that you have prohibited it but
your kid is sneaking around and trying
to find ways around your rules well that
look I understand that I mean I totally
understand even now with my kids as
young as they are it's making a rule is
no guarantee that it's gonna be followed
of course and as kids get older they're
gonna be better at breaking the rules so
I understand all that but you still make
the rule there's still a value and
saying to your kids no you can't you
can't know snapchat you can't through
snapchat
they get around it and they find a way
and you know then and you find out about
it you got to punish him I mean that's
the that's the back and forth that
happens in parenting I get that but to
say as a parent oh yeah sure fine go
ahead and use that whatever fine that's
the thing I don't get but it's a tool
for sexting okay that's what it is
so just there's no reason your kid needs
to be on but I want to talk about what I
want to talk about is getting away from
snapchat for a minute
talk about is the biggest pitfall the
most toxic aspect of social media lots
of studies have been done talking about
its detrimental effects on a child's
mental health and well-being and all
that stuff but a lot of times I think
those studies they miss the worst thing
that they fail to capture the worst
thing about social media for kids and
the worst thing about social media for
kids the biggest disadvantage is
actually the thing that a lot of parents
think is the biggest advantage and that
is that's that social media this is what
parents who are justifying it they'll
say something like well social media it
allows a allows our kids to network and
to stay in touch with their friends
first of all your kit your 12 year old
kid doesn't need to network okay that's
not a thing a 12 year old needs to do
but second as far as staying in touch
with his friends that's the problem
that's the whole problem with it
is the staying in touch with his friends
social media Rob's a child of his home
life of his family life social media and
the internet generally had become
replacements for the home and for the
family
and now when a kid gets home from school
after spending all day at school all day
around his friend who spends most of his
time at school around his friends and
you add in after-school activities and
when he's actually physically hanging
out with them so you add all that in
he's spending most of his time in his
life at this stage with his friends with
his peers but then he gets home from
school and he's with his family for that
brief period of time
but now he's still connected to his
peers he doesn't get away from them
now you have no time just as a family
without any of that stuff
his peers and that culture that's it's
always present he literally is carrying
it around with him everywhere attached
to it physically always that's the
problem he is
he has his computer and his phone and so
there's like this umbilical cord
connecting him to his peers all the time
always he remains completely immersed in
peer culture even when he's not
physically surrounded by it he is
attached to his peers always he hasn't
he has no life outside of them and
that's a bad thing
and if you think about it you with your
kid either presumably either goes to
school for most of the day or you
homeschool and if he goes to school from
us today you don't see him you know you
only see him briefly and when he comes
home the last thing you should want him
to do is to stay in touch with his
friends like as if he can't be away from
them for I mean can he not be away from
them for a few hours
so there if your kid you send your kid
away from school you shouldn't want them
to be on social media for that reason
and if you don't send your kid away from
for school any any home schools well
then if he's on social media all the
time you've basically negated one of the
one of the primary benefits of home
school which is that he's not immersed
in that peer culture and he's not
subject subject to it and and he's what
you know he's getting his cues from you
and from adults he's learning from
adults rather than learning to ape his
peers so that separation from peer
culture is one of the great benefits of
homeschool it's one of the it's the
point maybe not the point it's one of
the primary points of homeschooling but
then when you add in social media for
kids a social media addict on top of
that honestly there's almost no point
then in homeschooling you may as well
not do it because you you have erased
one of the great benefits of it
so either way
no matter what your kid does in terms of
schooling
I think we should not want our kids to
be on social media they don't need to be
on it there's really no benefit and the
one thing that's usually cited as a
benefit is actually the worst thing
about it
now here's the thing that this is really
talked about this before this is really
what lies at the root of the suicide and
depression epidemic among our kids
we've talked about before how suicide is
on the rise suicide is much more common
among teenagers and preteens today that
it's ever been before
this is something that you talk to an
older person you talk to someone who's
60 or 70 years old and they'll tell you
this is just you never heard about when
they were growing up this is you didn't
hear about this you never heard about a
13 year old committing suicide this is
this is this happens now frequently it's
terrible it's tragic and a lot of times
we'll chalk it up to bullying we'll say
well they're bullied in school and
that's what led to it but that doesn't
tell the full story
the problem is not just that kids are
bullied at school
the problem is that bullying has has
such a deep effect on kids because
they're so desperate to find approval
and affirmation from their peers because
they're so immersed in this culture and
they can't escape it
the point is children have always been
mistreated by their peers that's another
thing if you talk to someone who's 60 or
70 years old they'll tell you that Oh
bullying happened when when when I was a
kid it was it was probably worse than it
is now which maybe is true
but if you're 60 years old think back to
when you were 12
maybe bullying happened then and it was
a terrible thing but then what what what
at the end of the school day what
happened you went home
and there was an Internet there wasn't a
smartphone there wasn't social media
wasn't any of that so you you went home
and now you were away from them you were
away from that environment and yet you
had to go back to and maybe you dreaded
that but there was a break
there was this oasis of time where you
were not around your peers or subjected
to them or to their opinions and you so
it was not like you didn't feel like
every second of your day you had to
spend desperately searching for approval
from your peers because there were these
big chunks of time where you were not
around them at all
that is now gone
because of the phones smartphones and
social media the kids they never escape
each other anymore they're always with
each other either physically or in the
cyber realm they're always around each
other always they're always in that
world so it's not it's it's it's not
that some kids are more mistreated now
by their peers it's that they're now
more attached to their peers than
they've ever been before
which means that you
they're not accepted by their peers if
they're mocked if they're treated
cruelly that has a much deeper impact on
them
because this is their whole life
is there Pierce that's so that's where a
lot of this bullying epidemic and
suicide depression all the stuff and
kids terrible thing that's where a lot
of it comes from is that attachment that
orientation that kids have where they
are completely immersed in this world
together in this kind of fog that just
follows them around and they never get
away from it they never get a break
and they don't want to break because
it's compulsive internet social media
phones it is a it is it's something that
breeds compulsion
so they at some level they might want to
escape it but at another another level
they're dependent on it addicted to it
practically so you that's when parents
need to step in and give them the thing
that they really need and more and at a
deeper level want even though they don't
know it which is a break
and we have to force that on our kids
but whether a kid is bullied or not this
is a problem and people in my generation
you know people that are my generation
people that are around my age we have
kind of a unique perspective on this
because if you're about my age then you
probably be you probably remember you
remember as I do a childhood where the
internet really wasn't a thing and
social media wasn't a thing and you also
remember half of a childhood where the
internet was a dominant force in your
life
and if you're like me if you're my age
then there's this very sudden dividing
line like before internet and then after
internet and it all happened very sudden
for me it was probably I think it was
around eighth grade seventh eighth grade
right heading into high school
and before that point from birth to
about eighth grade the internet didn't
exist and it existed in some form but it
wasn't ubiquitous people weren't using
it it was just a novelty AOL in 1995 was
I didn't have a o L in 1995 but it was
not it did not even begin kids kids that
are younger don't know this but the
Internet in like 1995 94 before that it
existed but it did not even begin to
resemble what we have now it was it
basically was you wouldn't even
recognize it as the Internet so it was
just kind of a novelty for a while and
so you know it didn't we didn't even
have a computer for a long time
basically didn't exist but very suddenly
right as I came into high school
everything changed and people had that's
when AOL was the big thing I think our
first the version of AOL was AOL I think
2.0 or 3.0 and I think what really
changed everything was that was that was
the communication mechanism so you had
the AOL buddy list and Instant Messenger
and then you also had myspace came along
shortly after that you had chat rooms
when I was a kid for a while chat rooms
were a big thing I don't even know if
chat rooms still exist do they I'm not
sure I feel like if they do they are now
probably 100% populated by sex predators
when I was a kid it was probably like
80% kids on chat rooms and then 20% sex
predators which was a dangerous
situation so but back then you had the
instant messenger you had chat rooms you
had MySpace which came along shortly
after that and out of nowhere
all this stuff became a defining feature
of our lives as kids we still didn't
have phones with the internet and the
internet still wasn't anything like it
is now but it was similar in that you
came home from school and the main thing
that you did was you got on the computer
and you were messaging through Instant
Messenger you were messaging people from
school
and through the broader internet
experience you're connected with other
people who you didn't even know and you
assumed where your peers but maybe they
weren't
and I distinctly remember this as kind
of a revolutionary concept for me as a
kid but I would come home from school
and the school culture the pure culture
would migrate onto the Internet and so I
could stay immersed in
and then that culture also changes on
the internet a little bit too because
now you can be more uninhibited you have
more control over how you present
yourself you could you're willing to say
things to people over instant messenger
that you wouldn't say in real life so
then there's this exchange where pure
culture migrates to the Internet
things change their dynamic changes and
that bleeds back over into the physical
interaction so very quickly began it
began to change your personal
relationships to it so I remember all
this happening people my age we remember
this I thought it was pretty fun at the
time but
I didn't see what was really happening
and I didn't see that even even at this
early stage it had consumed my home life
in my family life replaced it
the internet wasn't as ubiquitous as it
is now it had already done
and even though my parents did a good
job of regulating it they were they were
more on top of that than most parents
were of the kids my age but this was
also people didn't really understand
what they were dealing with they didn't
understand the internet it all happened
pretty quickly for most of us and for
parents I think a lot of parents and my
parents generation were kind of fumbling
around trying to like they didn't see
this coming it's when they first started
having kids they didn't factor in the
internet at all wasn't even on the radar
screen and then all of a sudden you've
got this thing and it's taken over
everyone's life and parents are like
what are we supposed to do about this
so my parents did the best they could
but it but it still became this dominant
force and so there's this dividing line
the internet came onto the scene kind of
split our childhood into two and now you
can distinctly remember childhood before
internet and after Internet and it's not
hard for me to see now that the before
internet chunk was much better
there were more blue skies and trees and
scrape knees and pick up football games
and everything during that first half
so the thing that we desperately need to
give our kids and that they desperately
need to receive from us is a life
outside of this
outside of not just outside of the
internet but outside of their their peer
circle outside of that
we take it for granted these days
that a kid will get to a certain age
I hear this from older parents all the
time they tell me like like it's
inevitable like it's going to happen
there's nothing you can do about it so
we take it for granted that a kid will
get to a certain age maybe 12 or 12 or
13 something like that
and the duck the dichotomy between you
and your kid will drastically and
suddenly shift
and a kid will come to almost hate his
family really all of a sudden out of
nowhere there will be this sudden shift
where the kid has wants nothing to do
with his family and basically hates them
and we talk about this now like it's
normal and natural it's a natural part
of growing up it's just the way it is
now it is the way it is but it's not
natural and it's not normal and it
doesn't need to be that way
obviously it's always been the case that
a kid will grow and and he's gonna
become less dependent less emotionally
dependent on his parents on his family
and that's part of the part of the
growing process but this thing we have
now where a kid becomes a teenager and
just severs himself completely
emotionally from his parents and then
teenagers have now their own culture in
their own world their own universe their
own language their own everything and
adults not are not allowed to access it
or be a part of it that is not normal
I'm here to tell you that's not how
things have worked throughout human
history it's just not
that is that is a modern phenomenon it's
a phenomenon that began in the
Industrial Age and it just got worse
over time with the advent of these
different forms of media TV you know
going into the Internet and now it's
it's just gotten worse over time because
of all this and when you add it in these
kind of things in these areas where kids
could congregate and you know and these
when you gave them all these sort of
things that they could have to
themselves and that adults just didn't
understand
the advent of rock music was another
example it was just completely new and
foreign thing
that our parents generation it was sort
of their thing and their parents just
didn't even it was like a foreign
language they didn't understand it
and in the modern age it's just every
generation has its own thing has his own
music its own clothes it's a language
and again we take that for granted we
shouldn't take it for granted that's not
the way it's historically been for you
for the human species
and now it's gotten to the point where
it's just worse than it's ever been
before because the kids they carry
around their phones and they have their
own worlds where they interact with each
other and where they're with each other
and adults just can't access it and
don't understand it and they don't
really know like you see your kid all
day at his house looking at his phone
you don't really know what he's looking
at or what he's doing
he has his whole life to himself it's
not normal it's not natural
I admit it's a very difficult thing to
break free of in modern society but it
is possible because it is not a natural
and normal part of growing up we have
only decided that it must be for us now
so
a child wants to be on social media
so that he doesn't he doesn't miss out
but what I'm saying is missing out is
exactly what he needs
he doesn't need more ways to connect
with his friends he's already way too
connected to them he needs a break from
his friends he needs to have a life and
an identity outside of them
he needs to escape them
and I think the the home and the family
should be an escape from that
and that's what we have to give them and
that means at a minimum to begin with
keeping them off of social media because
nothing good can come of it
alright guys thanks for watching and
listening Godspeed have a have a great
weekend and a great Memorial Day so I'll
talk to you on Tuesday